up first we have the remiverse spider
this was one of 15 genetically designed
spiders on display during Peter Parker's
School field trip that bit his hand up
next is the web verse spider this
species of spider's scientific name was
aranius oscorpius as it was developed by
Dr Richard Parker Peter's dad and Dr
Kirk Connors the lizard while they
worked on cross species genetics at
Oscorp Industries next up is the
mysterious radioactive spider from the
MCU while we haven't seen the origins of
Tom Holland's Spider-Man abilities we do
know that it didn't come from Oscorp as
the company doesn't exist in the MCU but
it could have potentially come from
another multi-billion dollar tech
company Stark Industries next up we have
the 70 Spider-Man in this case Peter
himself created The Spider and it was a
radiated accidentally during Peter's lab
experiments in college which caused it
to Glow just like in the original Comics
up next is the Japanese Spider-Man who
was bitten by Gaia the Alien Spider the
bite came from a spider bracelet that
contains a needle which injected a
spider extract into takuya's blood
giving him spider powers and healing him
from the Mortal wounds he was suffering
from